pour la bonne cause une initiative des
chocs d'Élancourt le hockeyers ont
décidé de troquer leur cross pour des
tenues brillantes ce dimanche c'était
disco roller au profit du Téléthon les
gens mettent minimum 2 euros pour
rentrer qui sont entièrement bénéfice du
Téléthon la buvette les bénéfices vont
être juste pour le Téléthon et le but
c'est de faire une patinoire avec des
animations les plus conviviales possible
pour que les gens aient envie de revenir
un dimanche après-midi d'hiver en fait
chenille minute de vitesse et même pas
de danse en roller tout est possible le
plus classique c'est ça à l'époque des
quads et on peut tourner il y a plein de
choses comme ça on
peut danser
abusez
avec toute ma famille pour leur montrer
un peu ce qu'on fait sinon dans le club
vous êtes du club des chats vous faites
quoi moi je fais du roller une fois par
semaine j'apprends vous avez déjà
participé au Téléthon comme ça oui c'est
comme ça qu'on a découvert Élancourt
c'était
vraiment sympathique parce qu'on peut
venir avec les enfants les parents et ça
fait du bien le tourner
les chocs seront récoltés lors de cet
événement 487 euros face au succès
grandissant du disco roller Léo cayeurs
organiseront un nouveau rendez-vous pour
mardi gras vous pouvez d'ores et déjà
préparer vos déguisements et vos rollers
indispensables pour patiner